iron man 3 is one hell of an
entertaining movie Robert Downey jr. he
rocks it again as you can tell I have
faced on her like him see I'm Tony Stark
he is without a doubt the best actor and
character in this Marvel series there's
not a lot of action in this movie but
when the action is there it's [ __ ]
unique and entertaining as ever another
thing to this movie is surprisingly
really funny the visual effects is
top-notch it really complements the
action superb Lee well Ben Kingsley as
the mandarin he's barely in the [ __ ]
movie [ __ ] for the little bits of scenes
he has he does do a good job way better
than this performance in the love guru
Don Cheadle is roadie he's great as
roadie don't really give him a lot to do
as iron patriot I have a theory as to
why it's cuz he's black if you saw the
trailer for iron man 3 you're probably
like who the [ __ ] is boring but when you
watch the movie you instantly know who
he plays and you know what he does a
damn good job Gwyneth Paltrow's back as
Pepper Potts she at one point is just in
her bra has great ABS she doesn't have
as much screen time as she normally one
of the Iron Man movies but they do give
her some unique things to do I gotta say
there's a kid in the movie that Robert
Downey jr. plays off with a lot in this
film him in the kid have great chemistry
one of the best parts of this movie now
although they said it's one hell of an
entertaining flick it really does lack a
lot of emotional depth a lot of the
drama and intensity that is felt in a
lot of these Marvel movies is really not
felt here all they seem to do is go for
entertainment and being fun and it
succeeds in doing that but honestly it's
a little bit of a shallow film at the
end of it all unless they have to say is
they do some things that really go
against what the comics do and I'm
hearing a lot of debates about it and
you're gonna know exactly what I'm
talking about the number one thing to
change so once you see this movie and
I'm on the side where it [ __ ] sucks
to make manner in gay kidding although
that would be cool I would totally suck
the matter its dick you'll never see me
coming let me get straight to the point
here oh no I gotta say
man 3 did get it right all right guys go
to that comment box below and tell me
your favorite things about the new iron
man film what did you like what didn't
you like it is your favorite one in this
series and if you want to see a more
in-depth review of iron man 3 go ahead
and check out my show called reasons to
see that i doing that buddy jerry and my
cousin jessica is on the show people say
she's attractive but it would be weird
if i said that and last but not least if
you want to get updated every time one
of my reviews is out go ahead and
subscribe to my channel by clicking on
the link right here by my penis